150 feet below Grand Central Terminal
there's another terminal being created
to bring the Long Island Railroad into
Grand Central Terminal area in New York
City
[Music]
I've been working underground since 1966
40 some-odd years
[Applause]
the appearance of the underground area
is wet dark dank noisy smelly mostly
from diesel fumes or the powder residue
from explosives
the dangers that everybody deals with
underground our first of all collapse
that's the most inherent danger of the
underground industry as Rock stands for
a period of time it tends to relax and
it tends to get loose and it tends to
fall out it has to be watched constantly
it's not a good environment to be lacks
you have to be on your toes all the time
and you have to be well aware of what's
going on around you and what people are
doing next to you and what you're doing
next to them you're dealing with people
who use depending on and who are
depending on you and that gives the
sense of satisfaction camaraderie that
typical day-to-day office jobs don't
have
the technology now certainly speeds
things up as far as production back 40
years ago equipment was more primitive
than probably 400 years ago was even
more primitive than that when they did
tunnels and if you go all the way back
to the Romans when they did tunnel they
just heated the rock and threw water on
it and fractured it so tunneling isn't a
new experience that's been around for a
long time
all the workers underground with
exceptionally operating engineers are
sandhogs
whatever goes on underground the
sandhogs do it
even if you're not a rough tough person
you have to become that way or at least
become steel to the fact that everybody
around you is and you may not want to be
but if you want to work there you have
to come fit it
they have to be rough and tough they
have to be gruff they have to work hard
they have to listen to people scream and
holler because screaming and hollering
over the noises down there is the only
way to communicate
every day that you could go home and say
that you didn't cause anyone else to get
hurt this is a good day
[Music]